impeachment hearings today I'm sure some
of you watch these just crazy I was
watching it I was glued to that I think
everyone here at the office we didn't
write any comedy here no we did but we
were really glued to the said why yeah
you know who didn't watch yeah big
surprise President Trump claims he did
not watch the televised impeachment
hearings that he didn't watch yeah when
asked what he was doing Trump said I was
cleaning out my desk
[Applause]
what could he possibly have in his desk
the Burger King right now he has the
burger he has just a bunch of Burger
King crowns they can of the meal any
sentimental about I remember that when I
was a good burger of course the
Republicans are trying to mount a
defense Republican Congressman Mike
Turner said that the Constitution does
not admit hearsay yeah Turner then
admitted he doesn't know that firsthand
it's just something he heard somewhere
today the new evidence against President
Trump was called damning some say this
could end his presidency
no I'm wait I'm sorry this joke was from
two years ago
that joke is also from one year ago and
six months ago
we have note we've used that cute card
like 18 times Groundhog Day the cue card
yeah